[Music]
frozen
uh keep your stuff here i'm gonna take
over for this next story
uh well this next segment as a matter of
fact because it's wednesday and you know
what wednesday means it's tuesday so
well it's a patreon show i apologize i'm
so used to it it's a patreon show
tuesday in texas it's too this tuesday
in texas it's a patreon show so you know
what that means
we have to cover the retards so
here is
um
oh [ __ ] we have to cover the retards um
so yesterday of course everybody saw the
bobby lee thing the whole the whole
incident with bobby lee and his wife and
brandon and all that well the uh fighter
and the kid
to kick off their show
bobby uh bobby lee is somebody i love
very much we both do yes but bobby but
people have been talking on uh he he
went online and he he went on and talked
about somebody who spoke to him in a
very rough bullying manner okay
that wasn't anybody but me
so uh what you're seeing here
is uh somebody falling on the sword
that's what we call falling on the old
sword right there because there's
probably a lot of
look
we overlooked that whole new york times
article that came out about you
but now we need you to do us a favor
yeah because you want to stay in the
club now keep it keep in mind
i don't believe the people that accuse
brian callan i think they're liars we
saw one and we saw one in a video the
last a couple weeks ago trying to do
stand up she's a [ __ ] ass that one
she's a crazy lady so i want to be clear
here yeah i don't buy it i don't buy it
i never did
we defended brian callan and i've goofed
on brian calling him but that was
absolutely not true that's where
crushing puss and playing sports came
from
from him getting mad at us but i mean we
didn't buy that [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] that was wrong and they
were absolutely if you even look into it
for a second they were absolutely lying
um but yes brian is falling on the sword
but because what we saw yesterday though
was
bobby lee saying it was a group it was a
group of people so
okay
right frozen that's what he said right
group of people okay specifically set a
group a group of people okay i just want
to make sure i'm the guy i'm the one who
did it
not not chris not theo not joe rogan for
sure definitely not definitely not joe
rogan definitely get back to joe rogan
this is definitely not joe rose it
wasn't brendan no no this was all about
brendan guys please be nice to brendan v
he's literally [ __ ] the one of the
top comments is
uh one of the top comments is like this
looks like a parent defending their bad
child in the principal's office yes
that was on me okay he missed a couple
days that was my fault
the union rep is jerking me around
not sam it was me okay it was me austin
it was me all over the higher power was
brian callan yeah
and as you hire professional legal
counsel and professionals to deal with
this can i say somebody no you shut you
you be quiet i'll deal with you when we
get home shut the [ __ ] up i will deal
with you when we get home okay all right
big trouble mister i'm gonna discipline
my son yeah i am in charge of me okay if
anyone's gonna spank i'm not against
spanking him but if someone's gonna do
it it's gonna be me
this is really
weird
and i'm gonna i'm gonna explain this but
i wanna first own up to everything that
i did because what i did at the end of
the day the way i spoke to bobby who's
somebody i love
who didn't deserve the word nobody
deserves to be just attacked but then
why did you do it brian like that's the
point i'm trying to understand look
seriously do we ever bully anybody you
ever see us i agree with you it is wrong
to just bully people all the time you
know look at me and royce we always
treat everybody with dignity and respect
and understand something here
to pick on a helpless little asian man
who cannot defend himself and who has
absolutely low self-esteem is wrong no
exactly
shut up [ __ ] up frozen shut up do you
think i will end you oh my god
that you run a subreddit that hates me
and you know what [ __ ] i'm gonna
blackmail you peace out you will never
ever show your face again
sorry guys i apologize frozen's a little
crazy today yeah he's i don't know he's
wired up or something
this is uh
this is like watching
a guy that was
with three other guys and they went in a
drive-by shooting and killed people
and he's like just shows up to the
police station it's like it was me i
acted alone it was just me
it's i'm i'm solely responsible for this
like just to get everybody else off he's
acting like every single one of puff
daddy's friends
friend everyone the puff daddy has ever
had in his life
that was in him i shot up the club and
he promised me when i got out i get a
record deal and he got out and he didn't
get a record deal
no he just got deported say this too
i know i'm six for 250 pounds
from grenoble friends
see what
he's about to correct himself
he's gonna say 255.
55. i know i'm 255 pounds i know i look
like this stuff doesn't bother me it
hurts no
no
no sorry if this is one thing
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry brandon
do you think you're hiding it well
because you're not like you're
maintaining a really good exterior on
this
it's just a brave face feelings man it
always has to say it always has to say
the least i don't talk about it yeah
nobody wants me to come on here and talk
about you know how my feelings are hurt
because brandon
i get it and it's the same thing when
people make fun of us right like
i get it we make fun of people people
gonna make fun of you that's [ __ ] how
this is the way you go as they say
so i understand that you know
um
but but i've seen you sit there and like
go through girls entire instagrams and
say how they're ugly and or how you [ __ ]
like don't pretend like you're this
person putting out positive energy on
the internet you know
that's not the masking thing to do do
you like the mic arm it's not the
masking thing to do it's no he did it no
he didn't no he did it was my fault i
talked over it did he really say that
i'm asking
no
masking thing dude no he didn't no he
didn't ask he didn't do no he didn't no
he didn't okay here we go you know how
my feelings are hurt because that's not
the masking thing to do
that's not the masking thing to do
and you always want to stay masking
you know
he's so brain dead okay i'm sorry
i want to know like honestly
aren't you is anyone ever curious to
find out if brendan schaub
used to speak like this before the ufc
i'm serious like
you know you almost wonder if he really
was like a better speaker and then like
maybe it is the seat masking masking
talk about it yeah nobody wants me to
come on here and talk about you know how
my feelings are hurt because that's not
the masking thing to do
we're never going to get past it i can't
it's a huge joke
it's like he's having a stroke right now
sorry man
sorry man that's a [ __ ]
i can't if i i can't well we'll play it
again because if i play it again we're
not gonna get past it we have to get
past it there's more stuff
talk about you know how my feelings are
hurt because that's not the masking
thing to do
yeah come on we're going to do it
we got it i'm telling you now so all you
guys know
it hurts my feelings more than you know
no i know well that's
probably not the best thing to declare
on the internet yeah i wouldn't do that
not on social media i didn't leave
social media because social media left
me boy
you don't think i want to see my friends
and family and other comics and peers
post stuff and stuff like that no but
how come this doesn't happen other
comics and peers
you know
maybe it's because some people believe
those comics earned it and some people
think you don't right
i i love that stuff
i left it was so toxic it was so evil
that i don't want to describe that
anymore
handle social media god bless you man i
wish i could i'm too sensitive so
i know because i look like this you guys
think it's okay and it doesn't bother me
yes it really hurts myself so this is
what you think because i'm so like
physically gorgeous
i'm so i'm so beautiful and i'm rich as
[ __ ] yeah and my wife bother me and my
wife is hot and my children are awesome
yeah bro and even the chicks i cheat
with are hot yeah allegedly allegedly
tries to
where the way i spoke to bobby is
unacceptable
the way i spoke to bobby and he said
something to me that rea that i i'll
never forget he said i've been bullied
by guys like you my whole life and it
stops now
i believe that statement i do believe
bobby did say that to him
um
i
don't understand his mentality
i i don't understand why he
if bobby is the friend the way he says
he is i don't understand why he came at
him so
[ __ ] hard and the last thing i don't
understand is why the [ __ ] are brendan
chob's jeans rolled up well as we said
in the intro
many moons ago
it's even in the intro you played today
that's
he rolls them up so they almost look
like capris which is super gay
this is a teaching moment for anybody
younger listen take a minute when you're
really upset when you feel like you're
justified when you feel like you're
being attacked take a [ __ ] minute
think
think i'm way too old to have behaved
the way i did i'd say take longer than a
minute
well it just takes you longer to think
because of the brain injury yeah
it takes you a lot the the hamster the
hamster wheels rusted in this one
sometimes it takes me like five days b
i think inside his head is like whenever
they go inside homer's head you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
marge my brain is like a computer and i
file away grandpa's stories in a very
special place
some marches boobs
well i'm up there
okay i can't play too much of this